[Music]
Matthew McConaughey and Camila Alves we
teamed up with Samsung and Matthew just
keep living foundation for an exclusive
chat and as Brooke Anderson found out
the McConaughey's are just trying to
keep up with their three kids we have
the secret my PI goes to work everybody
goes to work we all go we go together
we're a traveling circus and I know for
us we have to spend time together not
just the kids can consume your lives
that's another great yes yes yes you
have to be intentional yeah you have to
intentionally have to know that it
wouldn't be here with that mom and dad
that's number one yes Matthew and
Camilla go way beyond just being mom and
dad to their own three kids their
foundation is all about helping
underprivileged high school kids what
was your inspiration for it well just
keep living is something that came to me
a few days after my father passed away
in 92 it was something that came to me
and trying to cope with him physically
no longer being here so I firmly
believed that I could still have a
relationship with him spiritually if I
just kept him his spirit alive and
that's we just keep living came from we
were at the frame gallery last night for
an event with foundation partner Samsung
displaying their new frame TV that
combines design with technology and
transforms into a beautiful work of art
when no one is watching gonna be here on
what I didn't know is a TV when I walked
in here but now I did one of the
foundations building blocks the
gratitude circle something the
McConaughey's practice at home what do
you hear from your children what are
they grateful thank you God for
cheeseballs favorite Brazilians that
[Music]
[Music]